-What you do is important.
Meanwhile, all I do is invent
little people in my head
and make them have imaginary
conversations with each other.
-Books change people's lives.
-Has something I've written
ever changed your life?
-Absolutely.
Absolutely.
My dining room table
was wobbly as hell...
-Oh, my God.
-...until your last book
came out.
It was like, perfect.
I'm telling you --
-Take me back to Logan, please.
-Logan cannot help you, Monk.
-Oh, my God.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here
with Tracee Ellis Ross!
That was a clip
from "American Fiction."
Now, I was not familiar
with the book.
It's "Erasure" that
it's based on, which is 2001?
-I'm not sure.
I'm actually grateful
I had not read the book,
because it let me come
to the script really clean.
-That's probably
a nice feeling, right?
I think sometimes, when there's
books that you're familiar with,
it's very hard to
step into the role.
-Yeah, Percival --
It's an extraordinary book.
I still have not read it.
That's problematic.
Bad student.
But it's a great movie.
I got to work
with Jeffrey Wright,
beautiful ensemble cast,
Issa Rae,
Sterling K. Brown,
Leslie Uggams.
And it's a story about a man
who's trying to make sense
of who he is in the world versus
how the world sees him.
And then it's really funny
with a lot of --
I don't know, I'm so honored
and proud to be in this movie.
-I've heard great things,
and I really love
Jeffrey Wright,
and I've been lucky enough
to have him here a few times.
And, you know,
obviously, he's acting,
but he laughs at you
in the clip.
I will say, in real life...
-Yes.
-...getting Jeffrey Wright
to laugh at you
feels like a huge compliment.
-Listen, Eddie Murphy
laughing at you is one thing.
-Yeah.
-Because the man laughs,
you know what I mean?
-He's a laugher.
Jeffrey Wright...
So he broke when we were --
we were shooting
the first couple of takes,
and you know, it was in a car,
so the director wasn't
in there to say "cut,"
so I had time to just go.
So I was just improvving
and talking, whatever.
And all of a sudden,
Jeffrey starts laughing.
I was like,
"What are you laughing at?"
And he's like, "You."
And I was like, "What?"
He's like, "You're funny."
I'm like,
"I know. We're acting!
What are you doing,
Jeffrey Wright, huh?"
And then I was like, "Oh,
my God, I can make him laugh.
I'm going to keep going."
-It was so much fun.
-I do not blame you at all.
-Oh, it was fantastic.
What an actor he is.
-He's the best.
He is the best.
-[ Gasps ] Oh, my Lord.
-But I'm going to say this.
You got an Eddie Murphy project.
-I can't.
-Jeffrey Wright project.
-Stop. Stop it.
-But you turned up in a movie
that might be
the biggest one of all.
-Let me tell you something.
I'm gonna be famous.
You guys...
-Did you know
this one was coming?
-No!
-Because this one --
-Alright, so you are in...
-You guys don't even know
what it is.
Just get excited, alright?
-This is so exciting.
Tracee was in a movie
that she didn't know
she was going to be in,
and that movie was
Beyonce's "Renaissance."
-What?
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, I have a guest appearance
in the
Beyonce "Renaissance" movie.
And yes, it's during
the mute challenge.
-So it was during
the mute challenge and you --
We're going to show the clip.
You seem very proud of yourself
for how you execute
the mute challenge.
-It's very embarrassing.
-It's very --
-It's not great.
So the mute challenge,
people know the mute challenge,
and I figured I really
didn't want to mess it up,
so I was just quiet
for most of the song.
-Let's take a look at
Tracee's wonderful cameo
in "Renaissance."
-I'm ready, I'm ready!
-♪ Everybody on mute ♪
[ Crowd quiets ]
♪ Look around,
it's me and my crew ♪
-I did it!
-Bravo!
[ Cheering ]
-Oh, my God, you know, Seth,
it's me and Cardi B.
We're both
in that little section.
-Really?
-Yeah, it's me and Cardi B.
-Wow, that makes sense.
-That's all I'm saying.
-You remind me
so much of each other.
-Don't you think?
-Yeah.
-When you go to
a giant concert like that
and you see a performer
of Beyonce's magnitude,
having grown up
as Diana Ross's daughter
and I'm assuming going to shows
like that from a very young age,
but yet it seems like you
can still be blown away by it.
-Well, first of all,
I'm a huge fan of Beyonce's,
love all of her music.
I don't go to a lot of concerts.
-That's what I was wondering.
-And I was very overwhelmed.
So because I'm my mom's child,
I, growing up,
being in a stadium,
I knew the set list,
so I knew when
the last song was,
when I was going to cut out.
It was I knew
where I was cutting out.
I was going backstage,
like, I wasn't just --
We got to that stadium
with my friends,
and I was like, "I don't know.
I don't think I can do this."
They're like, "You got this."
I was like, "I don't know."
I was like,
there's people everywhere!
Like, everywhere!
And so we did it,
and then I was standing
next to Jay-Z,
so when they started leaving,
I was like,
"Guys, we got to go now!"
-Yeah.
-"Jay-Z is leaving.
We got to go."
-Probably pretty smart.
-Yeah.
-And you got out
and everything was good?
-I got out,
and now I'm in the movie.
-Now you're in the movie.
-So worth it.
I dressed up like a ball.
What do you call it?
-A disco ball?
-I dressed up like a disco ball.
-I'm so happy that is what --
Like, if I had said disco ball
and it was something else,
you're like, "What?"
-No, it was --
"What did you say
I dressed as?"
-Seth, it wasn't a disco ball,
okay?
Yeah, like a disco ball.
-I am so happy
that you came back.
-I'm so glad to see you.
-It is the best to see you.
-You guys,
this is Tracee Ellis Ross.
-"Candy Cane Lane" is
streaming now on Prime Video,
and "American Fiction"
opens in select theaters
December 15th.
We're right back
with Mike Birbiglia, everybody!